I'm Lewin, CEO and founder of DivMob.
I have a small team of game developers in Ho Chi Minh City.
The company started three years ago and was staffed by five people.
Today, we have a team of forty employees,
Our games have been downloaded more than 40 million times.
The most important game among our games is Epic Heroes War.
(Vietnamese) I'm Minh, I'm a game designer at DivMob. </ I>
Epic Heroes War is popular for its easy play.
Users can take a large number of heroes from many cultures
You can also fight online battles with other players around the world.
Initially it was the source of most users who pay from the US and European countries.
$ Or more dollars were paid for jewelry and upgrades within the game.
But in emerging markets like Vietnam, the dollar is worth a lot of money.
In one dollar in Vietnam you can buy a full lunch.
We have always tried to try this price model in markets such as Vietnam, Thailand, Indonesia and Russia.
I'm Fok, an official at DivMob Technology.
We're very happy with Google's decision to lower costs for less than the dollar.
We have lowered our prices in certain markets because we believe that no one is buying because of prices.
To support new prices, we only needed to set the product price within the app
On the Google Developer Console. It's easy in management.
To highlight new prices, we've created a leader-facing feature
We provided it to users
Priced less than $ 1.
It has helped us convert a lot of free game users to paying users.
We have achieved immediate success.
Our daily dealings increased to 300%.
In addition, the number of users paying three times more than doubled.
This is important because users who pay are becoming more interactive and their income can be consistently monetized.
Today, six of our top 10 markets
In terms of number of transactions
The system uses prices below $.
I always seek to give freedom of innovation to my team.
We work together, eat together and play football together.
Here we are succeeding together.
Now what is our next goal? It's an easy goal.
We strive to create the best possible game.